I mean both both sides lie about that  girls get lip fillers and then guys say  I don't care about lip fillers but then  every phone knows that they get more  attention with lip fillers  yeah yeah and guys say we don't like  makeup and then every girl knows that  they're going to basically be ignored by  dudes if they don't wear makeup to the  club yeah dudes just are in denial about  what they're actually into if a dude  tells me I don't like make up on the  podcast I just like laugh in their face  because it's like you're just lying to  me yeah  yeah I mean I do think like men in  general prefer more maybe maybe I'm  biased but I think they prefer more  natural look for like long term